a Texas woman says she will challenge a
judge's decision to deny her a new trial
after sentencing her to five years in
prison for voter fraud crystal mason is
her name she was convicted in March of
voting illegally back in 2016 in the
presidential election Texas law makes a
forty three-year-old
ineligible to vote because she was on
probation for tax fraud at the time
Mason says she didn't know about this
law Michelle Miller shows us why critics
say her punishment outweighs a crime
certainly sounds like it can't wait to
hear Michelle good morning good morning
well crystal Mason showed up to vote and
when she did back in 2016 her name
wasn't on the voter roll so she was
asked to fill out and sign a provisional
ballot that's when elections workers
discovered she was a convicted felon I'm
wishing that I never voted that's how
I'm wishing I wishing that I never ever
went up there to vote crystal Mason says
she hadn't even planned on voting in the
2016 election until her mother convinced
her the former tax preparer was unpro
Batian after pleading guilty to
inflating her clients returns in 2012
she had served three of her five-year
sentence for that offense and was out on
bond she says no one ever told her she
was not allowed to vote under Texas law
right now I'm very overwhelmed with all
this everything is a shock you know
everything Mason was arrested in
February of this year and sentenced to
another five years in prison this time
for illegal voting Allison Grint ur is
Mason's attorney voting is something
that people should be scared of that's
the message pure and simple
and it certainly worked on crystal the
Tarrant County District Attorney
declined to comment but in a previous
statement said there were multiple
safeguards in place to keep crystal
Mason from breaking the law but she
still made that choice one of the things
that we're going to complain to the
appellate court is that this law really
isn't clear felon voting rights vary by
state in Maine and Vermont felons never
lose their right to vote Texas is one of
at least 21 states that prohibits felons
from voting and
their sentences have been fully served
including probation it's estimated that
more than 6 million Americans are barred
from voting because of felony
disenfranchisement laws
Christopher Yujin is a criminologist to
the University of Minnesota
he says Mason sentence goes too far any
group of six million voters who are left
out of the political conversation can
have a really important effect on both
the terms of the debate and the outcomes
of political of political elections now
Mason says she was held by a polling
officer when she cast her ballot and
according to one of our attorneys she
was never asked if she was a convicted
felon when she asked actually voted yes
we should know that there's some 12
states that bar you for life so
depending on what state you're in you
you can steal a smartphone and you will
have your voting or eligibility stripped
yeah interesting Michelle thank you so
much